تمارس رياضه اليوغا منذ الاف السنين لما
لها من فوائد صحيه واسعه النطاق سواء على
الصحه الجسديه او النفسيه طبعا اليوجا
فيها تمارين مرونه وقوه واستخدام وزن
الجسم وفيها تمارين بعلنز وتساعد على ضبط
الوزن وتساعد على تحسين المدى الحركي
تحسين العلاقه الجسديه حتى تحسين الاداء
الرياضي عند الرياضيات اما من الناحيه
العقليه والنفسيه اللي يوجد حارب القلق
وتحارب مشاكل النوم وتحارب ضغوطات يعني
شعور بضغوطات الحياه المختلفه والاستجابه
للتوتر تحسن من التركيز تحسن من الصفاء
الزينه
[موسيقى]
تحضر رياضه اليوغا في السعوديه بشعبيه
كبيره مع وجود قاعده واسعه من الممارسين
والمختصين فيها حيث بادره السعوديه بتاسيس
اول لجنه متخصصه لليوغا في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط لتنظيم هذه الرياضه واستقطاب
الكفاءات للمشاركه في المحافل المحليه
والدوليه امارس اليوجا تجربه من اربع سنين
وبعدها حصلت مدربه معتمد المنظمه العربيه
لوجا او شاركت في اليوغا السلام الى
اقامتها ونظمتها اللجنه السعوديه للوجه
فكانت اول بطوله في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والشرق الاوسط حصلت على المركز
الاول او الميداليه الذهبيه وما بين
تقريبا 70 مشترك من فئه 24 بنات كانوا
اكثرهم راح نقدم برامج كثير لتحديث فهمهم
وممارستهم لرياضه وايضا اكتشاف المواهب لو
يعني كان في همم موهبه تحتاج للصقل او
التبني طبعا الاجنه السعوديه اللي يوجع
اكيد راح تتم اهو اما بالنسبه للاعبين
المحترفين نصف المواهبهم وندربهم تدريب
اضافي حتى يوصلوا ان شاء الله للمستوى
المطلوب ونطمح فعلا للعالمين بادره اللجنه
السعوديه لليوغا بالتعاون مع الاتحاد
الرياضي للجامعه السعوديه لرفع الوعي بهذه
الرياضه وتحسين جوده الحياه للتمتع بالصحه
البدنيه والنفسيه للاجيال القادمه
لصباح العربيه حنان بخاري جدا